il va falloir qu'on est quand même qu'on
investisse ça a été dit aussi pas
simplement dans les secteurs d'avenir
moi je crois qu'il faut il faut il faut
investir dans tous les secteurs il faut
reconstruire sur de filières
industrielles qui ont été démantelés par
par la mondialisation 1
on a bien vu que on faisait plus de
médicaments en france on a vu la
faiblesse même de notre industrie
pharmaceutique de notre capacité à
produire des masques donc ça c'est sur
le plan sanitaire
mais à mon avis on a vu aussi dans cette
crise la fragilité de nos systèmes de
production parce que comme on dit en
économie on a des chaînes des chaînes de
production qui sont de plus en plus
longue c'est à dire que on va acheter à
des entreprises qui elles mêmes vont
acheter à d'autres entreprises et donc
on va se retrouver dépendant de toute
une série d'entreprises qui peuvent être
très très très éloignées les unes des
autres
or ça ça pose quand même un problème
lorsque les déplacements populations ne
sont plus ne sont plus faciles c'est à
dire que si vous avez un sous traitant
qui travaillent en chine et vous pouvais
plus aller en chine pour vérifier la
qualité du produit ou pour inspecter les
usines les ateliers
bah ça ça pose ça peut poser des
problèmes donc donc l'idée de
relocaliser une partie 1 pas tout bien
sûr mais une partie de la production me
semble me semble nécessaire mais ça ne
viendra pas spontanément il va falloir
quand même aider les entreprises les
accompagner et je pense que là il ya
tout un champ qui s'ouvre
[Musique]